[Music]
hi everyone hello i'm joined by elisa
james i'm michael hi ohm and if you saw
the title of the stream we're playing
ashe who is surprisingly available on
overwatch PTR how did that make you feel
I'm very excited because honestly I
thought they were gonna wait with a few
more days
me too I just got back from Blizzcon and
I got to play a ton of ash at Blizzcon
so I was like yo I got an exclusive I
got a player it's like oh she's on PTR
oh my god damn now everyone else is but
you know what that means that means
we're gonna stream it so yeah thank you
for joining me Lucy thank you for having
me you're gonna be playing today yes
over my lunch break but I've been
playing overwatch on ps4 instead of PC
yeah which is a very different game yeah
but we are playing the PC version
because that is what PTR is available on
and here we are I'm using my alt account
because I have a thing about using my
main account on live streams or afraid
is the wrong word I just don't need
y'all to know what my real accounts are
so that's also an excuse for why I'm
only level 25 yeah well PTR carries over
all also but you know what yeah it does
what yeah I just took mine I was like a
level 7 on PTR but I'm 250 or some
things yeah well you know what that's
enough talking that's uh let's get some
quick play
[Music]
ah man yeah you could try quitting out
and going back into with the game or if
you go into the arcade there is okay I
know I don't want to exit to the bleep
game what's gonna hit that stuff all
right yes all right let's try it again
let's go six No Limits
No Limit squad let's go all right yeah
so we're gonna try our best to play some
some ash so everyone out there who isn't
playing on PC R or on consoles who
primary play on consoles can see her in
action
here I like her move set I like our
abilities it definitely plays to my
style of game I know we have it I think
the overwatch talk kind of fell by the
wayside leading into 2017 so we didn't
really talk about all that much but I
usually play up groups specific yeah you
did just cover cover overwatch League
with your boy tam damn I miss you too
we're about to get ready for battle uh
my main I usually mean Farah because I
play it a lot of quake and unreal
tournament my time so she was like first
when overwatch launched I was like
that's my character also her and
Widowmaker but I also found that I don't
know I don't feel very useful when I
play widow-makers maybe because I suck
but it's someone who plays me to make it
to admit that you suck is you know it's
hard yeah but if you're a bad one you're
useless
yeah there's no like redeeming quality
if you're a bad Widowmaker
I think but as a long time
counter-strike player I think that
Widowmaker was my favorite initially
though I did lean turns towards Farah
cuz I could still be effective in some
sort of way but now with Ashe I think
that I'm really feeling her move set
which is like okay here we gonna show
you her primary fire is like a quick
semi-auto
her alt fire is an 80s which shoots
slower might be I think like mouths
mouths moving is on right now for me at
least nice there we go that's aw man I
hope the stream is working well yeah
sure
we could have them watch alright cool
kicking this off with two kills I got
some right there thank you oh yeah like
I said her aim-down-sights provides more
damage slower shots though but I think
it's I said this in our reach at that
just that should be up now about ash the
stream hey he's not in today tater tots
where are you when we need you John Luke
okay take a look at our feeds I'm going
to we're getting framedrops
I'm gonna count smooth mouth smoothing I
need to get rid of this or made my
sensitive ace too high
oh and I disconnected it yeah that would
been a real big problem oh I need to
play the objective get out of here hey
man don't hate
so let's play moira they play as other
characters when there's a new one
available on PTR
is it cuz we're streaming to too many
services man
every time I want to stream something
goes wrong god damn it
[Music]
hopefully you don't kill the stream
altogether thanks xsplit what kind of
processor does that thing have I have
some pretty juicy processors with a fee
on TV come on
I'm hurtin
oh great
Twitter stream like totally killing it
hey I can I can get behind that all
right hello hi hello welcome to the
GameSpot's live stream ok cool yay thank
you for that John Luke never streaming
the Twitter again I'm just kidding
alright so back to the back to the
subject at hand that's me oh okay and
also I play a lot of junk rat because
whenever you whenever you're in like a
bad like funk I feel like yeah I feel
like junk rat is a good one to just
low-skill yeah I could be effective
without having to think much but here
it's wild pretty Opie yeah so if you
don't know Bob is uh the ultimate for oh
damn that that dynamite was yeah it has
a quite as a long fuse which is I feel
like it's it's most effective when you
because you can toss it and then shoot
it in midair like that and you can do
some pretty clever things with it with
like people behind cover or I think it
goes through like a Reinhardt shield but
then you can't shoot it obviously but
you can kind of dispersed teams who
start to worry that the Dynamite's gonna
go off I think this has vsync on so then
but that's my excuse so is that a pro
diva which is a great name would be cool
if you could order Bob to attack certain
heroes and I just running me summon so
apparently well not apparently like like
Bob just goes wherever you're looking so
I guess if you aim yourself towards yeah
so you basically just turns and turns
into eternity autotargets anyone who's
within range and his ranches wild okay
that was normal dpi okay my dpi settings
see if that helps any but nah so yeah
she has this ATS which is quite powerful
right there I think two shots can take
out an enemy quite efficiently you got a
nice headshot oh wow
ah ah she healed dammit okay so yeah so
we got the normal shots we got the 80s
we have Bob who is our ultimate who does
autotargets everyone and mows everyone
down but we also have that I explained
that dynamite and also I think lastly
her coach gun which i think is a really
cool feature oh my god let's get mowed
down by Bob that's my boy what are you
doing
the Pope can get healed
and he could be put to sleep he could be
frozen by May he basically acts like a
normal character on the field
yeah I suspect some balancing may come
before he's officially a character and
overwatch I don't like the single
reloading kind of throws me off but does
it like if you cancel to your reload
made reload surely you oh yeah yeah she
she reloads single bullets at a time
which is uh Commedia hi get out my face
okay
not ma'am
what happened yay victory oh yeah yeah
so anyway her last ability I ain't get
to explain was her coach gun which can
be use in very different ways I like to
use it to boost myself up into the air
kind of like ferrets boosts jumps so I
can get some good shots on people
they also blast enemies away from you to
kind of create space and it does some
damage as well so this can be like a
last-ditch effort to do damage or save
yourself and Bob man's just bob is just
too much is that a pro Diva
what a great name what do you guys think
about Jennifer Hale the voice actress oh
that's Jennifer he'll come on a shepherd
oh yeah female chef I don't remember
Diablo 3 for voice acting but say as a
team sure we'll stay as a team we won
let me see let me think is there
anything else that you can do with
interesting you could do with ash ash is
pretty straightforward damage dealing
you know it's all about precision
suppose so if you like that sort of
thing if you're those Pro Call of Duty
players I guess or if you play a lot of
counter-strike like me Ash will be feel
right at home yeah I guess and that's
pretty much all there is to it alright
thanks for tuning in no I'm just kidding
quickly while you're searching oh yeah I
always find that so weird I was like
look at my skin oh wait what do we do
are we doing is capping that's gay pitt
hero gallery ash
skins so yeah we got Allen school some
bread going on so blood this black and
gold I like that blue and wait that
reminds me of someone or something it
looks like one of the over league teams
oh sure yeah oh I like this I like the
green and brown kind of color palette is
nice this one's called posh I don't know
no she's rocking it doesn't Victoria
Beckham have like that hair I don't know
who Victoria Beckham is the oh damn well
you were just talking about I know thing
about the Spice Girls
alright real quick oh that one was dope
down we'll get back to that after this
match definitely not playing junk rat
wash ok um yeah let's just see if we can
do good do well people say we've had
that before when people ask you how
you're on you go oh I'm good and they'll
go well every time I am on screen on a
video or a stream with you I always like
you always drop like these weird ass
phrases that I've never heard even
though you you hear them from Americans
apparently but that's your first mistake
hey that's a hot CBS property hey watch
young Sheldon CBS all access let's get
it actually I I have no opinion on young
Sheldon but apparently he brings in the
cash for CBS actually reppin the company
today so hey they paid a bill so I ain't
gonna complain is that a question or is
that a command cuz that's a good-ass
idea imagine happened like three bobs of
rain on one payload I did that a bunch
when I was playing at Blizzcon you just
call Bob onto the payload and the team
who's there just like what the hell just
happened
wait
Oh what am i doing
always I have this tendency to press
ships because I always play Widow and
Farah
I just when I need to escape I press
shift and with a sh it just oh yeah but
there there's their shift is I just I
use default controls and I that's what I
tend to do so this is actually the first
time I'm streaming overwatch for
GameSpot I know usually have Eric Tay or
Joey Joey plan and they are very good at
overwatch pleasantly mediocre because
you can still have fun and not good but
then I play characters like a different
kind of skill that's why I like about
overwatch is those characters for every
damage every skill level mine is really
low yeah the dynamite also does burn
damage which is pretty annoying if you
get hit by it very clutch for those a
whole lot of route rootin tootin shootin
they got a they got a nice skin already
got that that's like gangsters get or
the posh skin or not tiny blob waves
back when you wait for him
Oh cute Bob is uh when I was at a when I
went to when I went to Blizzcon and saw
the review I think more people were
hyped about Bob that they were about
hash I think if they weren't doing I
think if it wasn't gonna be thirty Bob
would have been a separate hero oh yeah
I guess I think 30 is gonna be that
[Music]
what am i what am i doing echo you mean
what a terrible showing I got nervous
man can mercy res Bob I don't think so I
would like to see that happen or I like
yeah it's either if his health gets low
enough or I think maybe that's a quick
look at the abilities right there
and we're getting we're getting attacked
man life strike says in all seriousness
no in all seriousness though there's
overwatch reading even of a damaged hero
doesn't the metal yeah yeah I suppose
yeah like watching the World Cup over
weekend
is it like three tying three heels
oh wait Echo's confirmed not to be 13 oh
okay okay I'll see my sensor maybe maybe
Jeff oh I would want to see I know you
and Tami I tapped him up at a yeah I saw
him because we in the interview sessions
for overwatch he was just chill and he's
on his phone he's five words up
we're playing the Tam's text eyes like
you up do we tell you about so earlier
in the year tomorrow and I went to
Blizzard and we shot a bunch of stuff by
the overwatch leak and we kind of did a
little mini series on that you can check
out games for gum we were enlisted and
they have this incredible library where
they have all these board games and
video games and consoles that anyone who
Blizzard to just like check out of a
library and they have these really cool
doors would like a little hatch in them
we stood there setting up the shot with
gelatin
I'm Jeff just kind of like cool past the
door and then sees us in like reverse
[Laughter]
and involves any book yep I put him in a
corner so it seems field of use block
yeah my bad as always bye-bye
jeff says razor read says the jeff says
there were six years being taught
currently here at this he's already in
fact next year will be main tank and 31
would probably be echo who's gonna be a
healer okay cool yeah cuz that would
balance out how many well depends on
what what kind of what type of what type
of hero would echo be support but what
kind of support would echo provide Josh
Kayla reckons healer okay I think that
makes sense you know yeah I guess not
the pale come on what y'all doing man
what's our team comp looked like it's
all ashes yeah but they have all ashes
as well there's a whole lot of Bob's
going on damn it it's over RIT
dude he takes a lot of damage like five
hunters something I don't know though
that fool is a tank main tank is Bob
yeah but again let I said this before is
that if your team is smart enough you
could probably take out Bob without much
of a hassle
there are ways around him it's just that
you know getting used to it takes time
so for now he definitely feels ope watch
the team just figured out how to do fire
and that's why you've got the fire
effect on Tobes new all by her fact
after the dynamite here here are 30 full
fire
I'm not doing are you oh I like the way
she says I'm oh jeez ah
keep pressing shift for some reason some
trash that's why it's like you just tell
everyone that you're trashed like it
kind of like negates any sort of
criticism that you can possibly face and
that is what I'm doing
I mean I'm peaking
come on a head shot go the hitboxes yeah
blame it on uh
hitboxes damn look at this no problem
for them oh okay cool yeah pretty simple
straightforward hero not much to learn I
think that yeah again you can do some
clever things like using coach Khan to
get above things when every generate
some see how much it propels you forward
if you shoot it behind you see if that's
like a sensible traversal tool I think
it's just I guess where's this fool you
ooh 10 seconds we're gonna stop the pelo
no thanks to me
repeating her lines are you want
dismantle that's what I do when I play
deep why you must be fun to play with oh
let's check out this play of the game
which is probably calling in Bob on fire
five people at the same time yep and I'm
a victim as well
Wow oh it's that the person that I
killed yeah see that's savage man hardly
ever do let's see yeah let's give it to
cool kill Street man all right how do
you uh how's your day going my day it's
good it's a hot Monday here in San
Francisco
oh I still cannot get over the fact
I don't know it's November it's November
but no I don't know what it is in
Fahrenheit but in Celsius it's like 18
degrees which is here yeah okay
where is back home it's like full oh
it's cold back home yeah so well yeah
zero is freezing this is like yeah I
guess it is you know I didn't like the
Bay Area all that much because it was
consistently : now I like the cold
weather but I do like seasons as well so
when I got here I was kind of like it's
it's it's so cold
it's like consistently cold and it's
also wind chills but for some reason
this year you know it's that's just real
man try and tell me otherwise I'm going
to so I'm gonna do like some because
it's all extra livestream yeah Friday so
make sure to donate and tune in for the
kids but I'm going to module and it's
gonna be cold and can you say what
you're doing in Montreal for a laugh
yeah these are the other two skins that
we didn't get to see Safari some get
some get to wear some shorts
cuz it's hot out there man it's hot in
the jungle I love that oh that's gross
no not go up again I think gangsters I
don't know I'm not I'm not a fan of like
the baggy like the bell bottoms and the
pinstripes
oh my mouth skinny jeans I like the pink
one this one yeah yeah I like I want
this yeah yeah she's just leader of the
deadlock gang uh-huh my girl you know
you know what's weird is that they they
reveal - as a character but also her
cinema like they revealed her within
McCree cinematic yeah and basically
McCree just like poems are in in the
cinematic and like the Kree gets away
with whatever he was doing and it's like
oh by the way that that person that
McCree just like totally shut down is
your new character like oh I guess
oh wait if can we I wonder if she has
any route 66 specific voice lines
oh is that also here gallery that's okay
she won the divorce and McCree got no
kids and asked if the gang apparently
Michael Chi was saying that they never
dated oh okay
well good friends there are respected
rivals maybe they were pals in the gang
oh oh so she's like Dutch I guess and
then macri's just like john marston
but not as violent invite dead one yeah
and read that one so no read dead 2
spoilers yeah anyway so I have only
played Red Dead one as well so or Red
Dead Redemption once I haven't played
Red Dead Revolver it was like a xbox 360
launch title or came out look at the
skin I like this the deep green with the
gold yeah
is that Proteus says how is Ashe is she
blatantly ever I would say Bob Bob her
her ultimate is overpowered now I do
suspect people like I said before I
suspect people will try and we'll be
able to figure out how to counter Bob
but as it stands he's pretty much pretty
Opie no one is playing
yeah so you're gonna get like a ton of
Bob's raining down at the same time I
should probably play the objective oh
there's a whatsit is that a pro Winston
has a pro Winston let's move this pail
or get the card for okay okay yeah that
seems like a useful Oh put me to sleep
I'll put you to bed
what's gonna take care of that Oh Matt
Padgett yeah they're the ones who made
you that's sweet Castle video I do need
to piss me off no no Castlevania anime
not don't call it anime don't call me
you don't call me a pearl ash actually
you can watch this watch this [ __ ] right
here uh Joseph lamonta says does high
alt charge feel too fast I don't know
I can't really can we tell all right I
feels fine maybe that's another way to
balance the power of Bob so he says
anyone else don't get this update on PC
it's just of the public tester region
yeah you just gonna so just make sure
you've selected the right thing and I'll
drop down before yeah you don't have to
install yeah you don't have to install
anything new just click on the drop down
to opt into the PTR and you should be
good you could try out ash
oh my god I can't land this damn shot ah
I'm a pro ash man you know - yeah not
sure when she's gonna be out on Xbox and
ps4 but I assume they're gonna try and
balance as much as possible yeah I think
I was so I was talking to
overwatch peeps and so I asked him say
what can can we play her and they said
sometime next month and I suspected that
was yeah but that was like so I guess
they interpret that as like when she's
gonna be released fully I should have
probably asked when she gonna hit PTR no
people did I don't think they only said
okay well yeah Monday the Monday after
Blizzcon is pretty soon I'm still
recovering from my trip not that they
went ham or anything well yeah I had to
recover from that that was oh man yeah
we good we went to Roscoe's got some
chicken waffles boy - it was good oh I
also got I got biscuits smothered in
gravy and I got a huge slice of
cornbread and also had like an Arnold
Palmer
I street lemonade mix half ice tea half
lemonade okay it's very tasty I like it
because yeah it was it golfer I think
our IP is can you can someone in the
chat tell me
while I continue to get wrecked my place
for tonight
are you sure you are on the PTR and not
just in regular overwatch because she's
not in regular yet she's just on the
public test
oh let me charge my old suck and drop it
on the pillow before we win come on let
me let me have this do something wait
that's that's my teammate I can't on my
96 do some Bob let's go ah damn it
Oh now he starts killing people
see it's got triple kill like that I
ain't do nothing man
took a little a little bit I guess it's
all cuz a Bob dead as well and we've
been doing this around the office is
that everyone's talking like a really
bad oh yeah
gross Hey well we're all tipping our
hats to each other even though we're not
wearing hats that's how we greet each
other when we pass by in the hallways
now howdy pardner I really say how do
you normally yeah I also say y'all
regularly - OH objective time we got it
let me commend myself if you can waive
it Bob can you emo like if I do an emo
and he will reflect it I don't know like
if you wave at him ya know wave back so
if I like dab will Bob dab - he'll gross
oh never suggests dabbing please
yeah like maybe Bob is the new doll oh
yeah huh let's give it a shot
how do you know not Reinhart us a really
good Reinhard cosplay at uh oh I think I
saw pictures of that yeah Joey took a
nice picture of him sick Reinhart also
saw a sick everything really
cosplayers go all out you gotta get some
I follow I think it small cosplay I
think that he is the guy who does all
the official Geralt of Rivia and the
cyber part oh yeah
the stuff that he does with his
girlfriend is incredible and he does all
these like Instagram stories where he'll
do builds and stuff and I'm like man
cosplaying is fun I've dabbled in it a
little bit here and there
very yeah very good
goro majima from Yakuza yeah so that's a
lot of fun you know I I've come to
understand the power of cosplays now
it's you look at yourself in the
reflection like damn I thought she was
just a video game character but you're
me yeah so that's kind of cool and I saw
a lot of that at Blizzcon have you
cosplayed lose me like a lazy diva was
it like the casual clothes so no no so I
kind of just printed
oh yeah nice oh thanks already dudes the
Divas Bunny on - yeah and it's simple
it's fine it can be cumbersome to do
cosplay as well I'm quiet I'm exiting
the desktop psych like I can't do it on
streem I can only recover
yeah oh yay the power of dynamite that
feels all right Ryan we don't know when
she's on console because Blizzard hasn't
reveals I'm just gonna be on console but
usually it's gonna be a couple weeks
because they have to go through PTR
testing first to make sure that yeah
let's do some balance and do all that
stuff ultimate ain't balance yeah yeah
bob is great but he is Opie uh I'm out
US can you shoot the enemy dynamite and
destroy that um good question oh we here
to answer all of your questions
I'll get that shots Mythbusters are IP
Mythbusters is that is that going is it
oh this is what my doing
oh man that was a enemy dynomite
merci Sam says I don't think Bob is Opie
I don't know the range on Bob is quite
something and he has a ton of health
yeah
but he's only around for ten seconds but
I think that could be a break so yeah
Mythbusters is gone oh yeah discovery
which I didn't have I didn't have that
channel I had free of you I have no I
haven't had TV cable TV and the long ass
time yeah and I suspect most of you out
there don't know [ __ ] I pay attention
what's going on a good mercy yeah ash is
pretty squishy like she can't be taken
down pretty easily like two good shots
with ATS will take down another ash
ah
sick man that burn damage is really
clutch for her at least pretty excessive
like yeah it does a lot pop it Shh pull
it twist it pull it oh so apparently
Adam Adam Savage from Mythbusters hell
of a name yeah I actually know someone
called Adam Savage who is not the Adam
Savage posture runs a channel that
covers prop making and cosplay even
those videos covering now he makes ups
of full clusters of trance that is cool
how high does her shift launch oh let's
see
damn that high exactly that hot yes my
god my guy I'm playing with an all-new
mousepad all-new setup here that I
haven't used ah damnit McCree I have so
many excuses I have so many outs for how
bad I may play so that's just how it is
[Music]
always gotta validate your performance
somehow did you know our good friend
Janet Oh Oh red giant bombs Oh G camera
operator for Mythbusters
yeah that was his uh I don't know if
those first job he also worked for TFC
the Filipino channel here in the Bay
Area so homeboys been places he also
helped bit fill the stuff like props and
actual equipment that they use for
Mythbusters
yeah ask him about it used to be a
cosplayer and she made like costume
stuff and now she just straight-up works
on Star Wars Wow she makes costumes and
props to Star Wars
Hey so cool cosplay can get you places
man I think she I think she had her job
was an SFX artist she did
stop the payroll is there an interrupt
rush done with the coach gun or is it oh
I was gonna say it just blows the enemy
players back so it just creates a lot of
space so especially for getting like if
I guess if a reinhardt's trying to swing
at you and you just hit the coach gun
real quick that'll that'll pull push
them back and then push you back as well
so you create like twice the space and
then from there you can just start
cutting them down so that might be uh of
course in unless you pull wrap shield
but then it's better than being dead
I'll say that much okay have you noticed
any counters - she's very yeah I think
you know anyone could really take like
she does I haven't really many I mean
other than the jeez so much for the
dynamite other than the coach gun she
doesn't really have that many defense
mechanisms or like ways to get away from
yeah yeah those deals a lot of damage
with the good es call this fool is get
it nothing I like more than seeing a
play of a game where a person is dead
and like yeah what am i what hero like
of all time or an overwatch okay so so
worth overwatch so my favorite to play
like I said is Farah or Farah and but my
just like favorite hero just like seeing
Oh
Deva of course divas best girl favorite
superhero all-time cosmic ear you okay
from Yakuza those guys he's not even
isn't it because how does having these
supernatural abilities but he's a hero
in my heart
he said heroes but not super hero what
about you
who's your favorite hero overwatch my
favorite it's the name recognition right
yeah
no it's because I was playing it and I
was I never really used to play many
time and when you're getting used to
learning everyone I think Lucio is a
great guy to start with because his you
know his moves it's very simple he's got
lot of mobility and he could be very
useful and he's super useful and if
you're not killing people you are doing
well just by being there yeah it's very
good very effective stuff so yeah very
beginner friendly Tim loves Batman to
time does look I would say Batman or
Jean Grey do you gray oh okay yeah
alright that's cool I would say okay so
that my favorite heroes cosmic URI you
my favorite superhero though is probably
um ha that's a good ask question Nate
name some cuz I'm trying not to name
like Marvel as in the ones like the MCU
Jean Grey does not count and huge hikes
about the dog Phoenix movie adaptation
of that comment seems quite suicide
squad level
Oh dazzla is another great one Hassler
Dazzler was well she's still around but
in the I think was in 70s and 80s she
was the one who was also the pop star
and she would have liked a little
flashing okay yeah actually made a
Dazzler CD it was this multi-platform
media okay oh boy okay
I was just say maybe and now that I
think about it my favorite superhero is
either who'll probably Todoroki from oh
my hero academia I still or or Naruto
Uzumaki that baffles he's a superhero
he's bad dad but okay bad dads know
everyone in the office loves my hair
academia oh yes chastity and gadje both
when dress does practice yeah chasity
did an incredible fra p yeah cosplay and
gash was tokyo me the sparrow dark
shadow boy good boy
yeah and so I still haven't seen it and
then you know in the UK offers go time
and will and Dave who were watching a
bunch of weeds a bunch of I need to do
Ozark season to Momo who Ozark it's not
an animator okay Netflix I don't I have
a lot of anime to catch up on to you I'm
still working my way through killa kill
calicos dope I'm actually almost done
with little witch academia oh it's so
cute it's the cutest thing I ever seen I
swear I'll put on y'all like little
witch academia are we allowed to oh yeah
we should we should just like do uh like
a commentary Oh while we watch like a
like a film in 40s anime in 40s let's
take that idea alright we're gonna go on
for about another ten minutes or so
because we have an important meeting we
do
gamespot we streaming for the kids from
this Friday I see them all the relevant
videos and blog posts and stuff we're
gonna be going up soon I sure hope they
are yeah I sure hope it does
so we're gonna think about that in like
shoutouts my project for saying and Rico
glazes it's miss Karen oh he can be your
hero baby
trash
does anyone still play this game
regularly says Steve yes yeah a lot of
people still play this game before Red
Dead came up I saw actually before I
moved to America I would play this every
day and I still suck good consistent
yeah play Daniel I got got hella got is
that their numbers did I play well yeah
I did I have a really weird history with
wow like I went vanilla wah was out I
played it a bunch 7 2005 vanilla Wow
and then I dropped off after I like was
it something about the mines secret I
forgot what the mines recall but after
that I was like okay I think I've had my
fill I was playing with a bunch of
people in high school too
so they were helping me I don't know I
was like I'm not really feeling it then
when Burning Crusade came out I was like
oh I jump into this again and then I
fell off again
[Music]
I really wanted it was because my I
lived with my mum and my mum is
technologically not very advanced
she also paid for the internet
connection tricked her into getting you
a WoW subscription so I talked about
this deal and no one has ever heard of
heard of this company we have deals we
paid 5 pounds for dial-up so you're on a
time limit a time limit and it was what
year was this so I must have been at
least 2004 you had dial-up and 2009 I
think yeah so but anyway the time that
Wow was you know really hitting with
people it was the time that my internet
would take you know 3 hours to download
a song damn I didn't have internet or a
computer till about 2003 in my house so
I had it I had a PC and I played a lot
of Sims
that's that's that's what's up my dad
and like offline stuff but then I played
counter-strike my friends ah yes
operation flashpoint oh you played
operation flashpoint yeah dan that game
was hard but I was like hella into I
ain't trying to die right now I'm
probably gonna get dead it anyway by
somebody else real quick objectives now
available it more soap awesome just
because you're playing a new here
drop your game awareness yes excuse me
why do you call college/university
because I'm British and college for us
is when you are doing your a-levels aged
between 17 and 18 college
oh boy all right after this round we're
gonna have to probably hightail it man
you're um I was gonna ask you something
Lucy yeah oh you were on um you're on
kind of funnies extra live stream I was
oh what's that
that was so much fun it was great I was
only I was gonna do that balloon because
I was pretty tired after last week I
have been feeling so good and then I
went over like 3:00 p.m. I left at 2
a.m. I guess but it was great I loved
doing it you know to pimp ours again
Friday I see we're running all weekends
it's gonna be
US office UK office Australian office so
all your favorite GameSpot folks is
gonna be on there and then yesterday I
was yeah as was I this weekend come on
man
yeah it is it gets it gets hot up in
here I don't know how I don't know how
me and John Luke we streamed last week
we streamed pub 76 for four hours in his
room we was hurt and oh my god we was
hurtin it was pretty bad
we do what we can wow I am having a
three elimination seven deaths boy I'm
one to count Katie are but if it's if
it's me I'm gonna I'm gonna care about
it and apparently I don't care enough
right now I like her she's uh definitely
plays to my style which is oh damn try
to reload you know I didn't need to
reload
what am i doing I'm trying to I'm trying
to solo everything which is not how you
play overwatch because it's the team
game but I do like oh we just lost to be
loose yeah we lost
well it's good timing that I just got my
ass whoop because we are going to call
it a day yeah I like Ashe because she
plays to the way I would want to play
these games which is like precision
precision shooting that's me speaking as
a Counter Strike player and yeah I don't
know if shield you'll see her much on
the pro level stuff so I don't know if
she's like I'm gonna be a top to your
character or anything like that we will
see how maybe and also I'm definitely
interested to see what they do with Bob
because as it stands he's pretty Opie
but uh yeah new hero and overwatch is
always interesting I want a full Bob
short Bob short yeah maybe maybe maybe
we'll get one there's a whole bunch
other heroes they need animated shorts
because those are really good yeah still
want to see a little bit more a little
bit more different types of characters I
would say in the Ross through moving
forward but you know I can move said
yeah so obvious is that yeah alright any
last words
Lucy thank you for joining us make sure
to check out the extra livestream
beginning on Friday yep good weeks y'all
any live streams after this not after
this one but always come back around 11
o'clock a.m. Pacific time on GameSpot
calm GameSpot's YouTube page because
they're always streaming the latest
games also check out Ben Gingka and John
Luke's IP you played taiko no tatsujin
earlier today which is a really adorable
rhythm game if you're into taiko drums
alright with that let's get out of here
let's get to this meeting and we'll all
see you ow
well I'll see you again in the chat next
time because we love hanging out with
y'all